the continuing expansion of ibm cloud
for financial services the introduction
of the ibm analytics engine serverless
plan and versioning for ibm cloud object
storage all on this episode of ibm cloud
now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
i want to jump right in today with a
group of four exciting announcements
around the ibm cloud for financial
services which is continuing its rapid
expansion with additional banks and
ecosystem partners
first up is ibm's new agreement with
kasha bank one of the largest banks in
europe
ibm recently launched a new multi-zone
region in spain kasha bank will be
joining this mcr and embracing ibm cloud
for financial services for their hybrid
cloud strategy moving forward
second atos announced the creation of a
new financial services center of
excellence and further collaboration
with ibm around skills training and
services for the financial services
industry third banking software company
temenos announced the availability of
temenos transact with red hat openshift
on ibm cloud
and fourth zafin a leading cloud native
product and pricing platform for
financial institutions will onboard to
the cloud for financial services
it's exciting times for the ibm cloud
for financial services and the new
partners joining the expansive ecosystem
so click the link in the description of
this video to learn more
next up i'm thrilled to announce the
availability of the new ibm analytics
engine serverless plan
ibm analytics engine provides hadoop and
spark environments that optimize the
scaling of compute and storage by
separating the two
the new serverless plan takes this
optimization a step forward by offering
a way for you to get almost 100
utilization with spark instances
it's common today to see cluster
utilization for spark users range from
20 to 60
leaving a ton of compute resources on
the table
this new serverless plan offers a
consumption-based usage model so you
only pay for the compute resources you
consume and only consume what you need
simply put the analytics engine
serverless plan helps make spark easier
to consume and the new plans per second
billing helps you control costs
to learn more hit the link below
to finish things off let's take a look
at the new versioning feature on ibm
cloud object storage that aims to
protect your data against accidental
deletion or overwrites
when versioning is enabled on a cloud
object storage bucket multiple versions
of an object are automatically saved
this means you can easily recover data
from unintended user actions or
application failures
you can enable versioning at the bucket
level for any storage class and
versioning can also be suspended at any
time to stop creating new versions of
objects in the bucket
you can access this new versioning
feature on cloud object storage buckets
by using the ibm cloud console the rest
api or the sdk
to learn more about how to get started
hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloudnow if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in the cloud
now
you